già ospite abito in condominio
il tipo che sta sopra di me è il
classico vicino rumoroso quarantenne
scapolo divorziato bello e impossibile
che ogni tanto si porta a casa qualche
ragazza si fa sentire dicevamo ma la sua
particolarità è che appassionati di
aviazione un giorno ha deciso di
atterrare sul tetto di casa con un
elicottero
c'è un giorno sentiva tipo tutto un tot
humor si meraviglia ogni volta capiti
nulla intimorita è un giorno 88 88 casi
quasi che tu dice ciao ragazzi ben
tornate una nuova puntata di vita
buttata il tema della puntata di oggi è
vicini di casa per un tema così
importante ho deciso di fare un qualcosa
di nuovo
io solitamente all'interno degli studios
the casa mia ospito sempre parenti amici
o comunque persone che conosco oggi
invece ho pensato di ospitare
all'interno del mio canale una ragazza
che ho incrociato un po di volte con la
quale ci siamo sempre così sorrisi
presentate al volo mi ricordo ancora che
la prima va sempre detto ma perché sta
vieni qua e quindi è stata subito molto
simpatica e sto parlando della mia
vicina di casa emanuela ciao ciao a
tutti ho eccoci qui in possiamo dire che
noi è la prima volta che effettiva
effettiva diciamo ci conosciamo e subito
le rimasta delusa particolarmente e
anch'io devo dire che sono abbastanza
curioso di sapere capito perché tu sei
una brava dai tipo all'assemblea
come siamo almeno io mi sembra tu ci vai
ci sono andata quella volta che che
forse ha sgamato qualcosa che guglielmo
si va beh ne parleremo più avanti
no io non ci vado mai perché non c'è la
mia vita è già difficile cioè la serie
sco ma visti ci si scanna alle assemblee
di condominio a un condominio molto
tranquillo in realtà potrebbe succedere
qualcosa sui piedi dove ha visto che
super tecnica perfetta
va bene si è sbarazzata magari è la
normalità ma per me non so se guardarli
se guardato come ti pare da questo e per
tra quelle arti te ne rendi conto subito
se uno ai tempi o no tu ce le hai quindi
vai 30 segnando ai tempi il tipo il
tempo di andar male così è un posto
letto
certo la ies e poi con il giusto tempo
perfetto se fuori tempo è ok ti potrei
soffiare il naso tamponare col natale
allora dico solo che anche a noi sopra
mio c'è un uomo che ha come animale
domestico la gallina e che un giorno la
porta a spasso nel cortile di casa mia
che chiama ripetutamente giuditta galli
lega si chiama giuditta ma in più questa
gallina gli dà ascolto ogni volta che
lui la chiama lei lo segue fantastico è
capito la fortuna cappero il suo animale
domestico in realtà frutta 16 e bruciati
e di pensa quello della gallese che
tempo mi devi dare delle dritte rame le
hanno tu non hai bisogno
non ho davvero te lo dico
tranquillamente
guadagnano così che rimase zitto una
mattina sono stato svegliato non dalla
solita sveglia ma bensì da un toro in
nero che non gira come un matto che si
era rifugiato nel mio giardino
quello che ne rimane rodi non c'era
anche il mio vicino di casa puramente
piantavano motorio qualcosa sta sempre a
piantare qualcosa questo signore con il
vicino di casa parla al toro facendoli
ciao ciao
ma tu chi sei cosa ci fai qui ciao poco
dopo arriva ovviamente il padrone del di
questo toro ma originaria che appare mi
sento il mio vicino di casa che tra sé e
sé dice ma che bel manzo e rimesso a
scavare pensavo si fosse poi sbagliato
lui fu dato da un signore lì è tutto
finto non sto comprendendo col vicino
che nel suo giardino piantava forse
pomodori e parla un toro come se fosse
un coniglietto dava poi mi sembra un po
come il nostro vicino a pianta da una
vita da quando è entrato ha messo terra
ovunque piante ovunque e non cresce mai
niente non crescita per morgan lily
serial killer
e a questa roba tipo a limitata dove le
piante dovrebbero girare intorno cira
con le bustone nere ogni tanto escono da
veri dati da killer si è ancora che
potrebbe essere un killer non cresce
niente
avete fatto da cucina quindi hai fatto
un'affermazione sgradevole ma è vera
quindi non è un assassino
no è un assassino che era un buon
pollice verde allora camuffa la voce
anche perché sembra che sto per morire
gioco che ti ospita dieci reattori
vicini perché chi batte naidoo prima di
lui partite ma che vuoi ma puzza di
carogna anche per gli specchietti
squarciare gomme della macchina si
aspetta che tornato pezzo noti ritirato
perché interessante vederla ballare
tutti i tratti circondario per guidare
la cordata altri vicini di fa
schiacciare dalle camere e riescano a
filmare quello che succede nei cantoni
allora bravissimo si tesoro mio ma una
bella bella denuncia da buttarlo proprio
fuori subito da lì e metterlo
all'interno di una nuova casa che si
chiama carcere con delle sbarre
eroghiamo la puzza di carogna la sua voi
vi ricordate quel mi citino che aveva
poi la singola volta da allora ha dato
il via e quindi il mio box auto senso
c'è stato ha scritto autogrill e non
potevano uscendo ho il terrore io devo
andare come una pala un sacco nero e
dare al vicino consumatore
togliamoci questo dente cosa è successo
l'ho contattata tramite instagram
chiedendo a mio cugino di contattarla
tramite una sua amica che conosce
un'altra su mica che al mercato mio
padre comprò la bambina era stata tutta
questa catena acqua perché il mio cugino
la conosceva perché la sua amica della
sua amica nel mercato dio padre comprò
un giorno andò da lui disse o matese il
cugino di guglielmo calcola che conosco
una ragazza e dice che non va mai alle
assemblee e che tipo vogliono buttare la
roba che il suo ex ha lasciato in casa a
cala nel sottoscala ragazze io ho subito
avrei lasciato bruciare tutti quegli
oggetti e prima e quello è venuto poi
complice internet ecc
non so se lo vedi lì ancora una parte
restante che ha detto è tuo
possiamo farlo lì è rimasto o magari e
tipo l'appendiabito di mezza italia
questi ambienti un appendiabiti che noi
ma lasciato dicendomi che era mio
soprattutto la cosa positiva è che lui
comunque grazie
lui comunque si è portato i nove bustoni
che sapevano di piscio di gatto
l'importante a quello mi dispiace per il
condominio ma erano molto alterati no ma
teoricamente si stava ipotizzando che
cosa fare di quella roba lì stati subito
saltato tanato vero io quindi io la
nomea di quello ma un po cosa certa sono
certo io che ti ha difeso davvero non si
fa tra vicini giusto che anche gli altri
non e visivi prodotte rendi conto che è
un miracolo che a me ancora non mi hanno
fatto saltare fini ma l'ho comprato
questa casa esatto io possa essere il
vicino antipatico odioso non ha rivelato
il citofono
in realtà sopre murare la porta io mi
lancerò col deltaplano dal balcone ma
non si è mai sentito quando ho fatto il
karaoke
no per fortuna ho messo altri di questo
condominio ma non ne posso dire diciamo
che sono nel reparto 8 ott si sente
quanti posti a un letto matrimoniale
quanto uno ne vuole paese
esatto marino ottavo buongiorno nulla e
io al bagno comunicante con il salotto
di questa persona quindi ero al bagno
intanto di spiegare le missioni
giornaliere e anzi mare fortemente dall
altro lato della stanza al che
avvicinano l'orecchio perché comunque le
voleva ascoltare questa stessa soluzione
perché sentivo la padrona di casa dire
queste esatte parole
addirittura stiamo per avere lesa e
parole è un audio importante ragazzi
amore di mamma continua così si amore
dal portatore di mamma passione mi fa
impazzire e continuando così però almeno
mezz'ora la cosa diciamo che tu penserai
è un meraviglioso la sto facendo con il
figlio se non ancora peggio aveva due
cani e ha cominciato a dire che bel via
vai a morire ma bastava
il suo cane no no no no no no che pure è
tornata la giornata no no no no no no no
no
è nella sua testa che sia stato puro
questi no vabbè non sarà così da paura
per fortuna non ha buona memoria e per
fortuna lo dimenticherò fra poche ore
ciao sono qui con le mie coinquiline per
raccontarti che ormai da tre anni
abbiamo un amabile vicina del piano di
sotto che oltre ad appendere bambole
nude a testa in giù dal balcone ad avere
una targhetta sulla porta con scritto
quel canto l gli angioletti impiccati e
inseguirci con il faro della scopa
ululando su sottofondo profondo rosso
per dimostrarci il suo amore ci lascio
anche questi bigliettini sul portone del
condominio
ora ti alleghiamo il biglietto però
almeno scrive io non voglio capire
almeno almeno c'è un messaggio amoroso
scritto certo ladri tutti voi studenti
speriamo vi venga la
come siete voi auguri pulitevi auguri
tutto l'amore che ha attestato simpatica
beh sì è vero non sei uno studioso o se
è una testa di cavallo da portarle per
poter praticare dell'italiana questioni
extra di casa il rapito farà da parecchi
anni e bay professava soli di casa la
castità la purezza di consumare dopo il
matrimonio ma invece di casa che si
stava del trombamico diciamo periodo
c'era una persona diversa che faceva con
lei
dai un imbarazzo diciamo che lei
trombava tantissimo ea volte faceva cose
con più persone e cose simili
la cosa inquietante che l'aveva 67 anni
e trombati più di quanto trovo io mamma
mia ragazzi majkic lavoro e dare
prospetta qui abbiamo altri sei secondi
comunque è nulla con questi messaggi poi
volevo semplicemente dire complimenti
complimenti complimenti signor i
complimenti per la coerenza gli regge
proprio questi segni leggera da poco
[Risate]
ciao scusa
non siamo capaci il fan su facebook
comunque ti vogliamo mandare una
testimonianza dell'antica vecchio vicina
di casa nostra e dal prossimo audio
prima lei potrebbero mettere la
pubblicità trovare delle altre lo
aspetterei per vederla
[Musica]
ciao
si andava in persona elemente lo diceva
stava sul soffitto era un po alterato
era un po alterata così è difficilissimo
guarda come tonale adesso vai vai così
ti vogliono sentiamo l'audio con
l'ultimo barbara ciao io ti voglio
raccontare del mio ex vicino di casa che
era un pazzo furioso da galera lui
praticamente odiava profondamente i miei
cani tant'è che ogni volta che tornava
dal lavoro scendeva dalla macchina ci
girava verso mio giardino gli urlava
fate schifo pezzi di test di cose così
burlava queste cose ogni giorno ai miei
cani ma il punto massimo lo ha toccato
una notte quando si è messo davanti al
cancello di casa mia con il suo
telefonino a riprendere i miei cani che
abbaiavano urlandogli fate schifo
e cose così io non ho mai capito perché
anche perché aveva anche lui un cane non
lo so non è ormai inutile direi che lo
abbiamo denunciato la polizia ha
denunciato denuncia quella cosa inizia
con la d e non finisce con a domattina
così si fa ragazzi quando ci sono
veramente dei problemi serie grande la
posizione se invece che evita buttata la
polizia pezzi di fango che problema o
vedeva il loro qualcun altro vallo a
capire
dovremmo chiariti i nomi dei cani quali
erano pezzi siamo finalmente arrivati
alla fine di questo strano ci siamo resi
conto che l'italia è un paese terrazzi
le persone disagiate proprio se erano
già tante di quelle persone abitano
anche all'interno di questa dimora il
vostro condominio ecco ma allo stesso
tempo posso dire se un finto la più
fortunato i livelli si io farò vedere
quando verrò a un'assemblea questo video
in questo modo ci cacceranno esatto di
vita per tutti e due
che dire ringrazio tutti quanti voi che
avete seguito questo questo video e
ringrazio soprattutto the manuela e
verdura disponibilità non sono state
super super gentile ormai caffè cena il
sale perfetto capito quelle cose tipo
trovata che aspettiamo stessa cosa per
me effetto come sempre io vi invito a
iscrivervi a questo canale se non volete
perdere nessun video attivate anche la
notifica e che dire ci vediamo da questa
settimana con un altro video
ciao ciao ciao